leute hier bin ich wieder das erste mal
in 2022 eure mal wanne und wie könnten
wir das jahr besser starten als mit
einer neuen folge wie schmeckt und heute
fragen wir uns wie wohl die lauch suppe
aus emily in paris statt
[Musik]
es ist eine serie die im oktober 2020
startete und letztes jahr im dezember
folgte dann auch schon die zweite
staffel kurze zusammenfassung energie
ist in der marketing und werbe branche
unterwegs und lebt in chicago
sie bekommt für ein jahr die möglichkeit
in paris zu arbeiten
und ab da hängt sie halt dort rum ist
kosten trägt die teuersten
designerklamotten und lebt den
französischen lifestyle genauso wie sich
das amerikaner wohl vorstellen wenig
realistisch aber deshalb hat sie mir
besonders viel spaß gemacht weil sie
gerade so übertrieben ist und ganz
ehrlich wer braucht gerade schon
realität also ich nicht die laut suter
hat ihren großen auftritt in der vierten
folge der zweiten staffel als emily die
aufgabe bekommt dem lauch ein neues
image verpasst sie präsentiert im kunden
ihre idee mit einem schicken modischen
werbeclip und dem werbeslogan league
sieg oder wie sie auf deutsch sagt so
schicken lauf den will ich auch
raus an dieser stelle an die synchronen
abteilung gut gemacht dem kunden dass
die idee aber zu klischeehaft und da
kommt die chefin um die ecke mit der
fantastischen idee die magische
lauchsuppe für den lauch mit zu vermag
sie sagt die laut hoppe ist eine diät
nahrung für französische frauen sie
kochen den lauch trinken das wasser und
verlieren überschüssige kilos und da kam
auch schon zu einer kleinen schüler
waren und wenn ihr probleme mit dem
thema diät abnehmen ernährung habt und
euch das triggern könnte dann jetzt
lieber abschalten weil in diesem video
wird es mehr darüber gehen und ihr könnt
ja dann schon mal
und so schnell die zubereitung dieser
lauchsuppe klingt ist sie auch man
braucht dafür einen kilo bevor ihr aber
drauflos schnippelt ist es wichtig den
dreck ab zumal auch hat an der grünen
krone nämlich besonders viel ernst war
genau also gründlich waschen danach
schneidet ihnen in grobe stücke und
schaut wirklich in jede ritze ob sich
irgendwo noch erde versteckt ihr nehmt
euch euren top und schmeißt den lauch
hinein dann merkt ihr das ad hoc zu
klein ist und ihr wechsel zu einem
größeren nun gebt ihr so viel wasser
hinzu dass er auch abgedeckt das wasser
darf jetzt mit dem lauf auf koch dann
den deckel ab machen und für 30 minuten
in siedendem wasser lassen jetzt hat er
auch seinen geschmack abgegeben und die
stücke sagen nun europa
flüssigkeit das rezept für diese
französische abnehmen lauchsuppe habe
ich aus dem buch warum französische
frauen nicht dick werden
das wurde 2004 von mireille giuliano
publiziert und ist ein ratgeber der sich
mit bewussterem essen beschäftigt und
für menschen ist die ja so eine neue
lebensweise mit essen brauchen ganz
stumpf gesagt ihr seht ich habe da auch
schon ein bisschen was weg gelesen ich
finde dass tatsächlich ganz gut also
langsames essen und essen genießen das
ist natürlich etwas was jeder tun sollte
auf dieses buch bin ich in einem artikel
von netflix aufmerksam geworden die
gerade diese art von crashdiäten dort
auch kritisiert haben es wurde aber auch
in der serie selbst kritisiert emily
regt sich nämlich in der szene danach
darüber auf und sagt das ist ungesund
klingt sie sagt dass wir abmagerungskur
fördern sollen finde ich nicht so gut
viele dieser mode diäten sind gefährlich
in amerika sind jetzt gesundheit und
wellness angesagt einfach ein anderes
wort dafür oder dann schlägt sie kalt
gepressten lauf saft vor wovon alle
begeistert sind sie selbst irgendwie
nicht ganz so aber dann schmunzelt sie
ein bisschen und die szene geht auch
schon weiter in einem artikel von
newsweek werden crashdiäten in bezug auf
diese serie auch kritisiert aber sie
kritisieren auch die sehr dafür dass
emilys kritik über diesel auf suppen
diät nicht stark genug war die autorin
der serie haben die kritik bestimmt gut
gemeint und wollten dass da irgendwie
einsetzen aber es kamen wirklich über
wie er also das finde ich nicht so gut
gesundheit und wellness besser lauf saft
gepresst ist auch gut weil es geht
schneller naja finde ich eigentlich
nicht so groß naja ok dann machen wir
weiter und sie hatten aber auch schon in
der ersten staffel so eine fragwürdige
situationen wo ihre chefin stadt zu
essen gesagt hat ja ich rauche eine also
oder rauch eine stadt zu essen weil so
machen das ja die franzosen drängen
ganzen tag rotwein und rauchen um aber
noch mal auf den punkt zu kommen der
newsweek artikel und der netflix artikel
sind sich darüber einig dass crash
diäten nicht nur schlecht sind sondern
auch wirklich gefährlich sein können
denn aus solchen ich trinke war das
ganze wochenende nur lauch suppe oder
wochenlang nur 1000 kalorien zu sich
nehmen können ein wirklich ernsthafte
essstörungen entstehen und gerade bei so
jungen zuschauern wie in der million
paris zielgruppe sollte man oder man
besonders gut aufpasst was mich auch
noch zu einem punkt bringt und zwar das
erscheinungsbild der hauptdarsteller
denn sie ist ja schon sehr sehr schlank
man kann jetzt aber definitiv auch nicht
lily collins dafür kritisieren dass sie
zu dünn ist denn das ist in beide
richtungen nicht angemessen ob bei
untergewichtigen oder übergewichtigen
menschen die zeiten in dem wir sätze
hören wie ja so zehn kilo weniger würden
ihr schon gut tun oder on edis zu dünnen
die hat ja nichtmal kurven sollten in
der vergangenheit gegen dennoch finde
ich schon dass die serie in diesem punkt
eine explosive mischung bietet auf der
einen seite haben wir junge
beeinflussbare zuschauer in und auf der
anderen seite einen hauptcharakter mit
einem super fans job in einer
wundervollen stand und sie trägt jeden
tag fantastische outfits die man sich
niemals nach kaufen könnte weil es alles
designer mode ist und wer kann sich das
schon leisten ernsthaft in jeder szene
sieht sie aus wie ein model auf dem
laufsteg selbst im französischunterricht
und das möchte ich bitte alles ganz
genau so haben außer natürlich den
französischunterricht den hatte ich drei
jahre und das hat mir absolut nichts
gebracht aber alles andere bloß diesen
körper an denen anscheinend jedes outfit
super aussieht ja gerne ein ganz kleiner
lösungsvorschlag ich glaube wenn das
kostüm department sich bei paar outfits
für nicht so ganz körper betonende lux
entschieden hätte dann würde es nicht so
rüber kommen als würde man sagen wow
dieses kropp top und dieses dieser mini
rock sehen in einer size zero war
wirklich fantastisch aus weil ich hatte
teilweise das gefühl dass ich doch sehr
schnell mein körper mit ihrem verglichen
haben weil sie so fantastisch teilweise
aus und man möchte ja irgendwie sehen
also aussehen wie ihr merkt beschäftigt
mich das thema einfach gerade sehr mein
neujahrsvorsatz unter betone ich meiner
und das muss nicht teuer sein war es
mehr sport zu machen und mich gesünder
zu ernähren und ja ich möchte dadurch
den kalorien defizit erreichen abnehmen
damit ich wieder in ganz viele meine
hosen und so reinpasse weil ich habe
ganz viele klamotten im schrank die mir
leider nicht mehr passen weil ich
einfach wochenlang oder monatelang nicht
auf meine ernährung geachtet habe also
das habe ich natürlich gemacht ab dem
ersten erster habe ich dann weniger
gegessen mehr sport gemacht aber nach
zehn tagen habe ich gemerkt die balance
wirklich sehr wichtig denn ich habe mich
teilweise echt müde kaputt
unkonzentriert sind einfach schlecht
gefühlt weil ich nicht ganz genau wusste
was ich essen soll wie viel von was
dieses spiel ich hatte mir auch nicht
verinnerlicht dass der körper ja einen
grund umsatz hat das sind die kalorien
die unser körper braucht um die
lebenswichtigen organismen am laufen zu
halten unser herz muss erschlagen unsere
verdauung muss er laufen und unser hirn
denkt ja auch ganz schön viele kalorien
bei manchen mehr bei anderen halt
weniger die band will und dazu kommt ja
dann noch die eintrags aktivität dazu
spricht die energie und die kalorien die
wir brauchen um zum sport zu gehen zur
schule
unsere ausbildung zu machen also beruf
spazierengehen den haushalt machen dafür
brauchen wir energie es ist einfach eine
ganz individuelle geschichte wie viel
der körper braucht und wie viel man in
den defizit- gehen kann aber heutzutage
leben wieder auch in zeiten da kann man
auf youtube gehen seid ihr gerade es
gibt personaltrainer es gibt
ernährungscoach es gibt apps in denen
man auch rezeptvorschläge hat und der
ihm sagt du machst das und das so viel
kalorien schlag ich gehe vor also es
gibt wirklich hilfe die man auch dann in
anspruch nehmen sollte aber was macht
jetzt soll auch suppen wochenende mit
einem und dafür müssen wir uns wieder
die allerwichtigsten frage stellen wie
schmeckt die lauch suppe aus emily in
paris lang ist dieser satz ja also es
riecht im haus ein bisschen nach
broccoli
sie schmeckt besser als ihre nicht auf
jeden fall
[Musik]
das kann man jetzt echt gut trinken ein
ganzes wochenende lang ich muss mal ganz
kurz an meinen kühlschrank deswegen gebe
ich euch
das boot muss ich auch ein bisschen
kritisieren weil es empfiehlt wenn man
wirklich tollen hunger spürt im paarlauf
stücke zu essen also
[Musik]
nach kalten laucha ohne geschmack
also das muss ich erstmal mit der lauf
so grunder spüren also das schon besser
und hier haben wir die kalte version
davon in eine sektflasche rhein gekippt
emilys idee auch suppen saft
nur
noch eine sache kann man ja schon
irgendwie machen sowie felix lob recht
gerade der hat davon in seinem podcast
komische sack erzählt dass er auch ein
besseres körpergefühl hatte und vier
kilo verloren hat was in fünf tagen
wirklich schon sehr krass ist aber das
ist halt auch nicht für jedermann beim
ramadan zum beispiel wird ja auch wochen
lang gefastet und erst am abend gegessen
also am tag auch nichts getrunken nicht
gegessen das kann man schon machen und
einen lauf suchen wochenende wird einem
körperlich jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht
schaden man verliert dann über ein
wochenende zwei kilo freut sich am
montag auf der waage aber das ist halt
kein dauerhafter weg abnehmen bedeutet
nicht aufhören zu essen das ist jetzt
mein fazit von diesem video ich möchte
euch auf jeden fall nicht diät tipps
geben oder irgend etwas vorschreiben
denn für jeden funktioniert eine andere
ernährungsweise besser und wenn du dich
dabei gut fühlst dann ist das ja super
aber wenn es nicht so ist und du dich
nicht gut fühlst dann hol die
unterstützung und versuch ist so zu
machen dass es dir gut geht und wenn du
mit dem ganzen thema gar nichts zu tun
hast dann ist es auch super ich meine
das ganze leben dreht sich ja nicht um
welche figur habe ich gerade aber es ist
gerade für mich thema und ich werde die
nächsten wochen noch mehr darüber
sprechen über sport über ernährung über
das was gerade so in meinem leben
stattfindet denn das interessiert mich
gerade und ich versuche auch jeden tag
was neues zu lernen und einen gesunden
weg für mich zu finden wir sehen uns das
nächste mal wieder ich hoffe ihr hattet
spaß bei dem video macht diesel auch
suppen diätkur nicht
gibt bessere wege
[Musik]